[Music]  what's the makeup bag uh-oh  Kylie Jenner's daughter stormy is  already taking after her mama girl  you're pushin over makeup bags  six-month-old stormy attempted to get  her hands on a glittery pink makeup bag  showing early signs of entering the  family business  Kylie recently told Forbes magazine  she'd like to give her 900 million  dollar cosmetics company to her daughter  someday saying quote  maybe one day I'll pass this on to  stormy if she's into it Nora  what are you doing with my Mario palette  Stormies not the only makeup obsessed  Kardashian kid stop it  hey that's not nothing but I shut up get  back hey Kim and Kanye's five-year-old  daughter North was recently busted  painting her face with mom's eyeshadow  pallete I was getting ready today and  she was a little too quiet and I look  over and she's like destroying the  palette and has just blue eyeshadow all  over her entire face  [Applause]  you